Have you have you seen my discussion
with Muhammad A? Were you able to tune
in to that a bit?
>> I did see it. Yeah.
>> Okay. What What did you think? You think
he cooked?
>> So, I have mixed feelings about it,
>> man. If I'm being honest, if I'm keeping
it real, it's it was I think you
composed himself a lot better than he
did. And I know that that's kind of his
personality. That's kind of his thing to
kind of get under your skin. I I feel
like he didn't directly respond, but he
did have some type of response at the
end of it, but it just wasn't I don't
think it was sufficient for people
watching to be like, "Oh, well, he he
did it."
>> You know, I'm Muslim, so I appreciate
him for coming out and trying to give a
effort in talking about our religion in
a positive way that is the truth.
>> You think that that was an attempt to do
it in a positive way, calling me boy
with the undertone he was doing? You you
cool with that?
>> I I don't like that. I I don't like that
at all. This
>> and you you and this is the same thing I
asked to Jo and he agreed. You would
agree that doubt means to be uncertain
of the truth, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So the Quran is saying to Muhammad or
Allah is saying to Muhammad in the
Quran, if you are uncertain about the
truth, right, that we revealed to you,
then go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you. So
going to ask the people who read the
scripture is supposed to help him gain
certainty of the truth and what the
Quran is saying. Right.
>> Sure. So if going back and checking with
the people who read the scripture,
meaning the the previous scripture is
how Muhammad can be certain of what the
Quran is saying, this makes the previous
scriptures the standard of truth because
that's what's deciding on whether or not
the Quran is getting this stuff right or
not. The reason I don't agree with that
and I think that it's kind of a jump to
say that if we take for example and if I
were to tell you clouds are heavy. You
you look up at a cloud and you're like
well it's floating up in the air. How
can it be heavy? And then you look up at
the sky and you tell me the the cloud is
floating. How can it weigh a lot? If you
don't believe me you can go weigh it.
That doesn't necessarily mean that
weighing it is the standard of the
truth.
>> If I tell you the the cloud is heavy,
right? and you're maybe questioning it
and I say if you're doubting that the
cloud is heavy go ahead get a scale and
weigh it. That means that I am appealing
to a scale to substantiate what I'm
telling you.
>> Sure.
>> So if you do what I say and you use a
scale and you find out that wait
actually it's not heavy at all. It's you
can barely weigh it. It's so light you
can barely weigh it. then I was wrong
based on my own standard that I gave you
to test with.
>> Okay.
>> Right.
>> What you're what you're saying is fair
when you're talking to someone who's
smarter than the context. I don't know
that. Look, I don't know the context of
the neither does the job
>> the actual verse. I've heard it I've
heard it said that um what it's
referring to is like certain things
about the prophethood that like if if
Muhammad is if prophet Muhammad is
unsure about
>> there look there's there's there's some
scholars that talk about how it's
referring to the events of the previous
prophets and um about Muhammad's
prophethood about him being mentioned in
the previous scriptures and his
descriptions and stuff like that. So all
of that is entailed in there. So can we
agree that that according to this verse
the previous scriptures is a let's not
say just the because there could be
others but is a standard of truth for
the Quran.
>> I can't agree on that. I can't how can I
agree on that bro?
>> I've been saying I've been saying that
>> you understand exactly what I'm saying.
You get the argument. You get the
reasoning. You see the logic. You see
it. You know the implications of the
logic of the conclusion. And so that's
why you're you're you're refusing to
acknowledge it. You're saying yes, yes,
yes, yes, that makes sense. Yeah, that
makes sense. Yeah, I see that. Yeah,
that makes sense.
>> Conclusion, no. Right.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> You're saying yes. You're saying yes, it
has feathers. Yes, it has a beak. Uh,
yes, it flies south. You know, yes, it
lays eggs. Yes, it has wings, two wings.
Is it a bird? No. That's what you're
doing.
>> Okay. So yeah, I'm I'm going to agree
with what you're saying is that I
understand the implications and I
understand what you're trying to say and
I disagree.
>> No, you don't.
>> That's all I could say.
>> The point that I was bringing up
obviously was that there's an
inconsistency within the Quran itself.
The Quran affirms scriptures that it
also contradicts. It can't contradict
these scriptures and still be true
because these scriptures are true. So,
the Quran has to be in perfect alignment
with these scriptures or else it's
false.
>> I I I think that's exact. Again, I I'm
just looking at it, you know, like face
value because we're really talking about
1,400 years ago where like I said, you
know, it's I think it's pretty, you
know, concluded at this point that the
Bible is corrupt.
>> No, it's not. No, it's not. But let me
go with you again.
>> Okay. If it's corrupt, then the Quran is
still false for saying corrupted books
are true. For telling Muhammad to go to
corrupted books to clear up his doubts.
You see how that doesn't solve the
problem for the Quran?
>> Nah, it again it doesn't make sense
because at the time it could have been
fine. So what what is the relevance
nowadays?
>> All right, let's go with that. So at the
time of Muhammad, the scriptures were
good. Maybe after that that's when they
got tampered with and corrupted, right?
So here's the special thing about that
Karim is that we have the manuscripts
and the scrolls that existed prior to
Muhammad's time. So that would mean that
the scriptures we have today are are
good because that's what the Quran was
talking about.
>> How many years after Christ?
>> Yeah. So so the go the gospel was
written between like 40 40 to 60 years
after Jesus. Um the manuscripts that we
have are like about 90 to you know 100
200 years later. So we have manuscript
copies after Jesus but prior to
Muhammad.
>> Yeah. But again the corruption could
have taken place immediately after.
>> Okay. So now it's not that the
corruption was after Muhammad. It's that
the corruption was before Muhammad.
Right? Is that where we're going with
now?
>> The corruption was before Muhammad. No
after. Because as it says,
>> go to the people of the book. And if the
argument is that at the time it was not
corrupted, then you can't deviate from
that.
>> Exactly. So this means that from the
time that the apostles written the
gospel, wrote the gospel, all the way up
until Muhammad's time, which is 600
years, there's a 600 year gap. All all
all all the manuscripts
the things that was in the possession of
the Christians in that time in in that
time period is good to go. It's
preserved. We have those.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm. So what we have here is the first
600 years of the gospel is preserved.
It's good. Right. Up until Muhammad's
time it's good. We have those. We have
second century, 3rd century, fourth,
fifth, and sixth century manuscripts.
>> Okay, we have those. We have the
manuscripts that existed prior to
Muhammad, which would mean that the
scriptures that I have are not corrupted
from the Quran standpoint. We're good to
go.
>> So, it's it's it's exactly identical to
what you're hearing right now.
>> Yes. What we have we have we have those
manuscripts. And so, you know, obviously
you'll have uh if you go into textual
criticism, you'll have scribes make
mistakes, might copy an extra word or
line, a verse might be missing in one
manuscript that you'll have in another
manuscript.
>> Even if you said it was 40 years after,
a lot can happen in 40 years.
>> But you already agreed that those
scriptures are good cuz all of that is
before Muhammad's time. So, the
scriptures before Muhammad's time is
good. It doesn't matter how long after
Jesus our
>> Okay. Okay. Now I understand what you're
saying.
>> Mhm.
>> All right. Okay. All right. I'm going
just have to look at my research and or
do my research and see what's up.
>> Yeah, that's an honest answer. I was
running an argument with uh with
Muhammad Hab on 1094 demonstrating that
the Quran points to the previous
scriptures as being the standard of
truth over the Quran. Do you believe
that he gave a I don't know. Did you see
that portion of our discussion? And if
you did, do you think he gave a good
response?
>> He gave the educational response that
>> the education I'm sorry. You do you
remember what his response was, man?
>> It was a lot of words. I'm not going to
sit here and like I can give it all back
to you right now.
>> His response was Muhammad never doubted.
So next I mean that's word for word what
he said.
>> True.
>> You think that that's that was that was
an educated response to the argument?
Yeah, I think I think he just uh didn't
really want to deal with it because I
mean I can understand him not want to
deal with it because it's a topic that
gets brought up a lot and it's like it's
never been a topic in Islam anywhere
until you know YouTube has came out with
this Islamic dilemma. It's like
>> yeah the internet the first thing that
happened in Islam I'll tell you that
>> we we never had to go to the previous
scriptures. The verse says, "If you're
in doubt about what has been revealed to
you,
>> about what has been revealed to you,
>> then go and ask those the people then go
and ask the people who've been reading
the scripture before you." Right.
>> Yeah. But that mean just cuz you even if
you were to doubt
>> Does the Quran tell you to go to the
previous scriptures in this verse? If
you
>> if you are in doubt, then go ask the
previous people, the people with the
previous scriptures.
>> So the Quran is literally pointing you
back to the previous scriptures.
Correct. Yeah, I would say that.
>> So, what do you mean the Quran never
told you to go back to the previous
scripture? It literally does explicitly,
>> but not to find the truth. Not not to
not to say like they're going to tell
you
>> the truth.
>> You would agree that doubt means that
you are uncertain about the truth,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> You have some doubts meaning yes, you
have some some wavering
>> uncertainty about the truth. Okay. So if
you are uncertain about the truth, what
does Allah tell you to do to get
certainty of the truth?
>> Go to the previous scriptures.
>> So the Quran literally tells you to go
to the previous scriptures to get the
truth. Right?
>> If you are in doubt.
>> Now I want to do this for you. Just like
I told the first guest, so far in our
conversation, in going over this, you
have shown to one have better character
and decorum and temperament than
Muhammad Hijab, and two, you have
demonstrated that you can reason much
better than Muhammad Joab because it
only took us what a minute and maybe a
minute and a half to to agree to this.
And but that's the the debate stuff like
that's all that debate, you know, cuz he
can't let you and and you can't let him.
>> No.
>> Points across.
>> Nope. That's not has nothing to do with
that. What it is is but you're like you
you're you're you're right in one way
that he can't allow me to be right. Not
in this scene, not on this platform, not
in front of his audience. If he conceds,
he conceds my point and he lost. And
that's how he looks at it. It's a that
that's what it's about for him for for
guys like that. It's about winning and
losing. It's not about truth and
understanding. For me, I don't care who
I'm talking to. It could be hijab, that
big oaf, that lying coward. It could be
somebody as chill as you or the previous
two guests that I just had. I care about
understanding and truth, not about
getting one over on you. But if you show
an attitude, a temperament that that's
how you want to play this, I can match
that. I can I can match that and
humiliate you. I don't want to do that.
I would rather talk just like how you
and I are talking and honestly reasoning
about this stuff. That's what I care
about. Right? So, you are have
demonstrated to have a better attitude
and to care more about truth and
understanding than Muhammad Hijab.
That's just objectively speaking. And
the chat agrees. They're saying facts.
Facts. Look, look at them. Facts. Am I
Am I telling the truth, y'all? He better
than hijab already, right?
>> Don't do that. Don't do that. Don't do
that.
>> What do you mean don't do that? Look,
come on, somebody. I got fire emojis for
you.
>> I'm not gonna do that to brother Jab.
>> You don't You don't You don't got to do
that, man. I'll do it for you cuz I know
you know